So the burrito distribution governs
all sorts of other things too.
I mentioned
it governs the popularity of box,
the sales of books,
but it also,
it also characterizes the distribution
of everything that people produce.
So if you think of creative production
of any sort of artistic production,
industrial production,
it doesn't matter.
Almost everything fails
and a few things succeed beyond
anyone's wildest imagination.
Apple's a good example of that.
No,
I mean the iPhone,
they have their competitors,
but it's an extraordinarily dominant
product and they rake in billions of
dollars,
I think.
I don't know if apple is
valued at $1 trillion,
but it's close to that.
And that's a lot of money.
And I think,
if I remember correctly,
it's something like this.
I probably have the figures wrong,
but like the top 40 people,
the richest 40 people in the world have
as much money as the bottom 2 billion
right now.
You know,
it's not like they're stuffing
their mattresses with that money,
or they have a skyscraper full of cash.
That money is out in the economy
doing whatever money does.
So you know you can't spend $28 billion.
So,
and sometimes you can
even do some good with it.
You know,
Bill Gates seems to be doing
something reasonable with his money.
But the reason I'm telling you this is
because one of the things you should know
is that this proclivity for inequality
is pervasive among the creative products
of human beings.
It's the case with with
goals scored in hockey.
My son told me,
and he's a reliable source
on hockey statistics that,
okay,
if Wayne Gretzky,
if you don't count any of the points that
Wayne Gretzky managed with scoring is
still had enough points
just with assistance to have
more points than any hockey
player that ever played.
So you know,
even at the upper end of,
of of the distribution,
there's some person who's Ha,
they're so good at what they do.
And then there's another person that's
so much better than them that it's not
even comparable.
And so,
and the benefits flow to people
who are in that position.
And you can understand why.
I would say,
because I know,
let's say you start writing and
you get a book and a rare things,
very weird things to have happened.
And then some people
read it and they like it.
And then of course it's much more
likely that you'll get a next book.
And if people like that,
while it's even more likely
that you'll get a third book,
and then people start to know who you are,
and then because they know who you are,
they phone you up on offer you
opportunities and your network grows.
And it's like this exponential increase
in your reach and your capacity for
production and more and more flows to you.